irène chagnaud propose voyage sans
passeport
le chemin de fer franco y tient traverse
d'abord pendant désert n'était à
désertines et inhospitalière puis il
grimpe lentement pour arriver à addis
abeba se trouve à 2500 m alice abeba est
une des plus hautes capitales du monde
avec la paz en bolivie et la ville
sainte au tibet lhassa en chantant de la
gare toute la ville s'étale devant nous
alice abeba est aussi étendue que paris
en guise de bois de boulogne il ya des
forts et l'eucalyptus au milieu de la
vue voici les jardins du palais impérial
addis adeba là va avoir lieu la fête de
la croix de l'empereur
cette cérémonie rappelle ou plutôt
commémore l'arrivée et environ 600 ans
d'une part celle de la croix du christ
devant l'empereur sont rangés les
dépeceurs à ce sont à la fois les
danseurs et chanteurs de l'église et en
même temps ils connaissent les secrets
de la magie de l'astrologie et fabrique
des éoliennes
ils tiennent d'une main leur bâton
repris hier au reposoir sur lequel il
s'appuie parfois pour se délasser et de
l'autre main insiste le maniement du
sist repent dans leur danse est
semblable à celui des prêtres de
l'antique egypte qui figure sur les
bas-reliefs de l'époque pharaonique
leurs voix sont rythmées par le
tintement de sinistres et par des coups
de tambours frappé avec la paume de la
main
les chants des dépts aura son des
psalmodies vieille le 15e sa vente est
grave très étrangère a les oreilles
européennes selon les uns c'est ainsi
que david en s'élevant l'arche selon les
autres elle est une réminiscence païenne
éviter de l'antique et j
les lacs et du palais a porté sur des
plateaux d'argent des bouquets de fleurs
des champs
les bateaux circulent dans l'assistance
et chacun reçoit son bouquet la
distribution des fleurs donnant à chacun
son printemps et l'aspect payen d'une
cérémonie par ailleurs essentiellement
chrétiennes comme l'attestent seuls
trois d'or richement si les abysses
abeba est en liesse
car la ville fait son empereur hailé
sélassié nous sommes au théâtre
d'addis-abeba construit par des français
est inaugurée pour la circonstance
on y joue une pièce en trois actes en
amharique du premier ministre l'empereur
décide que deux actes suffit le
troisième a été coupé par ses soins
devant la porte de l'église saint
georges un vieux guérini une prison en
plus tient d'une main son pilier du
programme certes igor et les pierreries
et de l'autre ça lance sur sa tête une
coiffure en poils de singe et de
pendentif en or sur le parvis 2 est de
garde du corps en grande tenue à temps
de l'empereur qui va recevoir dans un
instant là bouna vêtue d'une chatte
blanche une peau de lion sur les épaules
voici le chef des gardes du corps à
droite de l'empereur
le cortège se forme et s'avance
lentement vers l'église saint georges
en tête la bounhar l'empereur la
poitrine barrée de bandes l'ordre
salomon en uniforme de maréchal et
coiffée du bicorne à plumes
l'impératrice suivi de ces dames
d'honneur ensuite prince héritier et sa
femme
le ministre de la défense nationale le
premier ministre et toute la suite
pénétrons à leur suite dans l'église où
le service va se prolonger pendant deux
heures en même temps il se passe
beaucoup de choses sur le tard à
l'arrivée du carrosse fabriquées
spécialement en belgique pour cette
occasion et qui prendra les souverains à
leur sortie et la danse des prêtres
accompagnés de leurs tambours
m
je
mais
sortie du tfg tout en noir à l'issue de
la cérémonie les rafraîchissements son
service une mutante l'emport l'atv des
serviteurs qui peuvent aider cajasol tel
salomon
suit le corps diplomatique
e
fazila c'est pour défiler devant leurs
emplois certains popoli coiffure à poils
blonds
après avoir traversé il a mille
franchissons les grilles du palais
impérial
le peuple tout entier à acclamer son
souverain qui en 25 ans de règne la
momie de la barbarie
aux temps modernes
irène janot vous a proposé un voyage
sans passeport d'otages rené gary script
jacqueline noirs sont alain gautier
illustration sonore dominic palladini
réalisation solans péters